GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO OUR
JOBS COMMITTEE JEDI COMMITTEE
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN HERE. AND WE
ARE GOING TO START TO AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE ARE GOING
TO WELCOME.
R. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SUSHI TO
PRESENTE BE FOR TWENTY SEVEN.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
GOOD MORNING.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT TO AB FOUR
TO SEVEN TO ESTABLISH.
THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION BEFORE GOING FURTHER
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE ON
PAGE NINE OF THE ANALYSIS AND
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
AND THAT TO CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO. I RECOGNIZE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY IS AN ICONIC INDUSTRY.
MUCH OF THE POST WAR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONNIE WAS BUILT ON
THE BACK OF THE AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE INDUSTRY.
AND CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
OUR COUNTRY AND THE WORLD AND
AEROSPACE INNOVATION.
AND ADVANCED MANUFACTURING YEAH
I MY AREA AND THE LOS ANGELES
SOUTH BAY AREA. WE HAVE
COMPANIES LIKE SPACEX ENGAGED IN
A MODERN DAY SPACE RACE.
TO PUT A MAN OR WOMAN ON MARS.
AND WE HAVE COMPANIES LIKE
BOEING THAT.
LEAD THE WORLD AND SATELLITE
MANUFACTURING.
NORTHRUP GRUMMOND CREATING
THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS.
BUILDING THE NEXT GENERATION
STEALTH BOMBER.
AS WELL AS THE JAMES WEBB SPACE
TELESCOPE.
THE MOST POWERFUL TELESCOPE SO
POWERFUL THEY CAN SEE THE FIRST
LIGHT FROM THE ORIGINAL BIG BANG
THE BEGINNING OF TIME.
SO.
BUT OUR LEADERSHIP AND.
THE.
THE NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
AEROSPACE.
.
INDUSTRY IS BEING CHALLENGED A
MANY STATES.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE TRYING
TO LOWER OUR. OUR ARCTIC NOW
COMPANIES IN OUR JOBS A TO THEIR
STATES.
AND SO WE NEED. A STATE
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE
PUBLIC PRIVATE LEADERSHIP.
FOR POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE. IN
SUPPORT OF OUR ICONIC CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
AYE M..
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE.
TWO REPRESENTATIVES.
.
I TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL A WE HAVE.
ALYSSA M. OFF FROM BOEING.
IN MICHAEL'S OFFICE ROOM SEE MPA
A MINIATURE.
YOU TO WORK THAT WAY FRITTATA
WHICH ONE WANTS TO GO FIRST. YET
HERE OKAY. AYE MORTY MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE I'M
MICHAEL SAW CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION.
AND IF FOR SOME I WAS A A THIS
IS A BIT OF A PERSONAL ISSUE FOR
ME BECAUSE MY FATHER.
WORKED IN AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURING FOR HIS ENTIRE
CAREER.
WITH TWO COMPANIES FIRST WITH
LOCKHEED AND LATER WITH WAR
WHICH BECAME GOODRICH. AYE
AEROSPACE SO THIS INDUSTRY
PROVIDED FOR MY FAMILY GROWING
UP IN THE ABLE ME. TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND ULTIMATELY TO BE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT HISTORY. OF PERSONALLY
BUT ALSO FOR THIS ECONOMICALLY
FOR THE CITY CALIFORNIA'S HE
SOMEONE EVER SAID THIS IS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR BUILDING
UP SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ON A POST WORLD WAR TWO ERA.
CURRENTLY PROVIDES WELL OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
DIRECT JOBS.
WE KNOW THAT IN THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR THERE'S
ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF TIMES
MULTIPLIER WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE.
SERVICE SECTOR JOBS FINANCIAL
SERVICES RESTAURANTS MOVIE
THEATERS DRY CLEANERS ETCETERA.
THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY THAT
LISTENING YOU MYRIAD SMALL
BUSINESS.
SUPPLY NETWORK AS WELL.
DOES THAT NUMBER GROWS
SIGNIFICANTLY AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
SO THIS INDUSTRY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
BOTH TO CALIFORNIA'S PASSED BUT
ALSO TO USE FUTURE.
Z. SOMEONE MEMBER NOTED WITH.
SPACE EXPLORATION AS WELL AS I
FUTURE SATELLITE.
DEVELOPMENT DEPLOYMENT.
AREA SO I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU.
ON BEHALF OF CAL FREES ME
FRACTURES TO. IMPLEMENT THIS
COMMISSION.
TO ENABLE THE STATE TO HAVE A
MORE FOCUSED EFFORT LOOKING AT
POLICIES THAT WOULD.
BENEFIT THE GROWTH OF THE SEC
CONTINUED GROWTH OF THE SECTOR
IMPORTANCE THE SEE CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT COME ALONG WITH THAT THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND MY NAME IS MELISSA AND LAW I
WHICH I ENTER ENTRY HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOEING COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOR TWENTY SEVEN.
I'M IN CALIFORNIA BOEING
ADVANCE SOME OF THE WORLD'S
MOST ADVANCED SATELLITES AND
SOLAR PANELS IF OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE.
AND ON TOP OF OUR EMPLOYMENT
MANUFACTURING FOOTPRINT WE SPEND
NEARLY SIX BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR ON SUPPLIERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION COMMISSION WILL PROVIDE
A VOICE FOR THE INDUSTRY SEVERAL
STATE FUNDED COMMISSIONS EXIST
FOR OTHER MAJOR INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M AND FRANKLY THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY TORSOS AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT
THE COMMISSION WILL WORK TO
REINVIGORATE CALIFORNIA'S
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND CONTINUE
ITS LEADERSIP AND INNOVATION
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING AND JOB
CREATION. SUITORS LIKELIER
DRIVER ON A BEFORE TWENTY SEVEN
THINK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND INTERRUPT JUST TO GO
AHEAD AND HAVE OUR SECRETARY
CALL ROLE. AND.
OR SECRETARY CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
YOU'RE.
VICE CHAIR TRAVéS ALAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON.
A SOMEONE A RODRIGUEZ.
OKAY THAT GIVES US A QUORUM SOUL
MOVE AHEAD AND JUST BEFORE WE
COULD GO AHEAD AND TAKE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I AM I DO
WANNA GO AHEAD AND.
REVIEW THAT TODAY'S AGENDA
THERE SIX BILLS ON FILE.
WE HAVE NO BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
REMOVED THERE ARE TWO BILLS ON
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR. AYE
AND.
WE WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING. AND DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE ANY ITEM FROM CONSENT.
OKAY.
AND THAT WE DO HAVE ONE VACANCY
ON OUR COMMITTEE SO THAT WILL
BE.
WORKED ON AND FOUGHT WILL GO
AHEAD DO WE HAVE ANYBODY FROM
OUR COMMITTEE THAT LIKE TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR. I KNOW
QUESTIONS JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS FORWARD I
HAD THE CHANCE TO TO GO DOWN I
SHOULD HAVE GIVEN YOU A HEADS
UP.
TO GOOD UNDER DISTRICT NC
SPACEX.
DURING THE BREAK IN WAS
FASCINATING WHAT'S GOING ON OVER
THERE NOT ONLY THE TIME OF THE
JOB CREATION ALSO THE TECHNOLOGY
IN AND JUST THE. THAT IN THE
FUTURE THAT YOU CAN SEE BEING
GOAL REALLY ON THE FACTORY
FLOOR.
OUTSIDE A CHANCE.
TO TOWARD DIED MY DISTRICT.
HAS A HUGE NORTHROP GRUMMAN
FACILITY IN THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT MY DESERVES NO
FOR FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE AND
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES BUT RIGHT
IN THE BACKYARD IN SUNNYVALE IS
HUGE NORTH ROMAN FACILITY. BY
THE MOVE THERE AFTER THE
NINETEEN OH SIX EARTHQUAKE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND SO IT'S BEEN THERE FOR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE YEARS.
AND IT'S.
AGAIN CREATE A PROVIDING YOU
KNOW REALLY GOOD PAYING.
MANUFACTURING JOBS WHILE ALSO
DIEM MAKING SOME OF THE MARINE
SYSTEMS THAT THAT HELP PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY.
SO YEAH I'M HAS A GREAT IDEA
AND JUST REALLY WANT TO SAY
THINGS TO BRING FORWARD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
WITHOUT TELL WILL OUT INVITE
THE AUDIENCE TO FREE OF ANY
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE SOME
CLOSING REMARKS I APPRECIATE TO
MISTER BERMAN'S COMMENTS SO? YOU
KNOW I I THINK THAT.
.
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE SOME OF
OUR. LEADING INNOVATORS IN OUR
COUNTRY LIKE ILAN MOSQUE
CONTINUING TO.
.
BUILD.
HIS SPACE HIS ROCKET SHIPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE REASON WHY WE HAVE YOU
KNOW COMPANIES LIKE NORTHROP AND
THE SILICON VALLEY.
IS BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE.
SOME THE MOST CREATIVE THE MOST
INNOVATIVE.
WORKFORCE AND IN CALIFORNIA
DESPITE THE HIGHER COST OF
MANUFACTURING IN IN IN OUR STATE
BUT.
IN A WEEK WE CAN'T RELY JUST ON
OUR LEGACY OF OF HAVING THIS
ICONIC INDUSTRY AND SO YOU KNOW
I'M HOPING THAT THIS COMMISSION
WILL.
.
PROVIDE THE LEADERSHIP THAT THE
THE FILM COMMISSION.
AND AND OTHER A SIMILAR STATE.
AYE COMMISSIONS HAVE PROVIDED
FOR THE INDUSTRY.
TO BE A BULL BULLY PULPIT FOR
THE INDUSTRY AND AND TO.
YOU KNOW CONTINUE PROPOSED.
.
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO. BE A
NATIONAL GLOBAL LEADERSHIP MEN
IN THE SPACE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I THINK YOU AND I TO HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS ON. UP FIRST WE
HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOTION FROM SOMEONE MEMBER
BERMAN SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SERVE ON TEST.
.
SPEAKING OF IN OUR BACKYARD AS
FAR AS THE AEROSPACE IN AND
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY.
WE HAVE SEVERAL MANUFACTURING
THAT CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FOR THE
AEROSPACE IN INDUSTRY ALCOA
WHO'S BEEN THERE FIFTY YEARS. OR
ACTUALLY MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS
NOW.
I'M MAKING THE FASTENER OR THE
BUT THE BOLT SO WE KNOW THAT NOT
ONLY ARE THEY LONGTIME EMPLOYERS
BUT THEY HAVE ADDED IN
CONTRIBUTED TO.
MANY OF OUR.
ACROSS THE WORLD NOT JUST
DIDN'T CALIFORNIA LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE THAT THERE'S OTHER
COUNTRIES TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THESE PARTS AND PIECES.
SO I SUPPORT IT AND I WAS ON
YOUR SELECT COMMITTEE WAS ABLE
TO GET OUT THERE AND HERE.
AND TOWARDS SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT ARE VERY SPECIFIC BUT WE'RE
HOPING THAT COME OUT TOWARDS
ORANGE COUNTY.
BUT WITH THAT THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND IN THIS
MOTION IS A DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS A
MISTER SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
SURE QUIRK SILVA. AYE QUIRK
SILVA AYE.
VICE CHAIR TRAVIS ALAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN.
BERMAN I ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SIRVENTES
CERVANTES AYE SEMINAR PATTERSON.
SOME MEMBER RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE VOTES STANDS FOR ZERO.
MINE AND JUST A ONE ADDITION
THAT I'M A MEMBER OF FONG IS A
CO AUTHOR AND THAT'S.
MAKE LIKE YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AND AS.
I BELIEVE I WILL BE UP NEXT SO
LET'S SEE MR BERMAN WHICH YOU
HAVE TO CHAIR.
OKAY.
BIG SHOES TO FILL.
TEMPORARILY
.
OKAY GREAT.
YOU'RE STARTING WITH.
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SEVEN.
AB ARE FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN A
REALLY ANYONE YOU WANT TO. SO
I'M HAPPY TO GO IN ANY ORDER YOU
WANT
OKAY.
THAT IS ONE SOBRE WHICH NUMBERS
ACT.
SEVEN FIVE.
OKAY.
THREE.
BUT FORGET SEVEN HERE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LET
ME FIRST EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN COMMENT
FIVE A OF THE ANALYSIS. A BE.
FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN MODIFIES THE
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESSES
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT
SMALL BUSINESS CAPITAL ACCESS
LOAN. PROGRAM FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
WORD INCREASE ENOUGH WE IN NO
WAY WANT TO CHANGE IT TO. TOO
HIGH HAVE LESS PARTICIPATION
THIS IS TO ADD THE PARTICIPATION
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND
PROVIDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
A NEW LOSS RESERVE PROGRAM TO
ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
ACCESSING CAPITAL TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO ME ES DE A
REQUIREMENTS AND AS WE KNOW MANY
OF US FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS HAS BEEN QUITE.
DIFFICULT FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TIED TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE CREATING SPACES FOR.
ADA.
.
CONFORMITY.
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY NO LOANS
HAVE RESULTED FROM THE PROGRAM
THE STAFF OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLLUTION. CONTROL FINANCING
AUTHORITY HAVE RECOMMENDED THE
CHANGES IN THIS BILL WITH ME
TODAY IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
I AT FROM THE FINANCING
AUTHORITY AND I'M GONNA LET HER
GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE YOURSELF
TO MAKE SOME SHORT COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF CDC FAA
WINNINGS WERE NAY WEBSTER
HAWKINS.
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING A CAL
CAP PROGRAM WHICH IS A LOAN LOSS
RESERVE A CREDIT ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
PRIOR TO THAT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
PROVIDING.
LOWER COST TO ACCESS TO CAPITAL
THROUGH OUR BOND PROGRAM FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY IN
UNDERSTANDING ON BOTH WHAT SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED.
TO ACCESS CAPITAL BUT AS WELL.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT WHAT LENDERS
NEED.
TED TO HELP THEM MAKING THOSE
LOANS ESPECIALLY IN.
UNCERTAIN ECONOMIC TIMES OR
WITH UNCERTAIN.
AT BUSINESS ACTIVITIES ARE
PROPOSED TO BE SUPPORTED BY THE
LOANS WE WERE THRILLED.
ED TO TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GOMEZ'S VISION OF A SPECIAL
PROGRAM TO USE ASSIST SMALL
BUSINESSES TO INCREASE THEIR
ACCESS.
TO AYE DISABLED CALIFORNIANS.
A IT YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
DISABILITY ACCESS.
AGGREGATES.
A LOT OF DATA ABOUT THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE LACK THERE OF
TWO OR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES AND A LOT OF TIMES
IT HAS TO DO WITH.
MINOR IMPROVEMENTS TO PARKING.
TWO ENTRANCES AND EXITS.
AND OTHER.
OUT ASPECTS OF THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS.
AND SO THIS PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED WITH.
THAT DIVISION OF MAKING IT
EASIER FOR THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES TO TO OPEN THEIR
DOORS.
BOTH FIGURATIVELY AND
PHYSICALLY TO DO IT CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES I'M
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF.
INCOME THAT THOSE HAVE
BUSINESSES COULD BE GENERATING
IF IF THEY BOTH.
IF THERE WERE MORE ACCESSIBLE.
AS THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
AND CHAIR NOTED WE HAVE
CURRENTLY NOT TO YET.
YET YET TO MAKE ANY LOANS UNDER
THE PROGRAM WE HAVE BEEN.
WE.
DEVELOPED AND IMPLEMENTED THE
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ACTIVELY AND OUTREACH THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ALSO TOGETHER WITH
GOBIZ.
ATTENDING A REGION'S FAR AND
WIDE IN ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND AND TALKING WITH
BUSINESSES WITH ADVOCATES AND
WITH LOCAL PLANNERS AND BUILDING
OFFICIALS. AND.
AND WHAT WHAT REMAINS TRUE IS
THAT THIS PROGRAM.
BEAN ORIGINALLY HAVE FOCUSED ON
THE TRUE MICRO BUSINESSES.
OUT MAY HAVE BEEN CAST A TOO
NARROW WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT OUR
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE IN
ADMINISTERING THE REGULAR CAL
CAP PROGRAMS THERE
THE-DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS
ALIGNS WITH THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES OR LESS. AND MOST OF
OUR LOANS ARE TO MICRO
BUSINESSES AND AND THE SAME IS
TRUE IN ANOTHER PROGRAM WE RUN
ON BEHALF OF A ARE BE FOR.
FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCK
UPGRADES AND.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THROUGH THIS
AMENDMENT.
THAT WE CAN.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
BUSINESSES.
MAKE THE LENDERS MORE
COMFORTABLE BY BEING ABLE TO
HAVE A MORE DIVERSE PORTFOLIO
WITH A FEW LARGER BUSINESSES BUT
STILL TRULY TARGET THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE MOST IN NEED
OF THIS PROGRAM SO.
THAT WE.
AS AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
I'M I'M VERY HAPPY ABOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS TO AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SEVEN I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
CONVENE MY MULTI MEMBER BOARD
YET SINCE THE MEMBER AMENDMENTS
WERE INTRODUCED. ON BUT I'M
GONNA BE RECOMMENDING THAT THEY
FULLY SUPPORT OF THIS LANGUAGE
AND HAPPY TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU TO TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM
SUCCESS.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
EVELYN I WILL HASN'T WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WERE ACROSS DISABILITY
ORGANIZATION WE REALLY THINK
THAT THIS IS A BILL THAT'S GOING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE MORE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO
MORE ACCESS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE GOING TO HAVE
WHICH IS OUR ULTIMATE GOAL FOR
OUR CONSTITUENCY SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ALLOTMENTS AND
REPRESENTING THE FINANCIAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATIONS LOCATED
WITHIN THE AYE BANK
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK PROVIDING
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEES
WORKING HAND IN HAND. WITH CAL
CAP.
IT WHICH RENEE'S PROGRAM AS
THIS GOES FORWARD I DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION TODAY BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THIS LOOKS LIKE A
BILL THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT AND OFFICIALLY AND AS AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD SO WE
APPRECIATE. THE AMENDMENT AS WAS
SAD AND I APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ANY. GUY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OUT A THEN THE MOTION
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
ANY COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FOR THIS IS ACTUALLY AN ISSUE I
WORKED ON LAST YEAR SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK IF I CAN CO
AUTHOR. YOU MAY AND WE LIKE TO
TO SEE BILLS. FROM ONE YEAR TO
THE NEXT YEAR AND SOMETIMES*
AND THOUGHT NO.
BUT THIS ACTUALLY IS ONE OF
THOSE BILLS IT'S A LITTLE BIT IN
REVERSE OF WHAT WE TYPICALLY SEE
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE FUNDING BUT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN OF THOSE TAKING
ADVANTAGE SO BY BROADENING. I
THINK THE DEFINITION WILL SEE
MORE PARTICIPANTS AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IS
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES GET IN
THE ACCESS AND OTHER.
.
THOSE PEOPLE THAT NEED THAT
ACCESS PHYSICALLY TO HAVE THAT
ACCESS SO WITHOUT I RESPECT FOR
LAYOFFS RIGHT AYE VOTE.
MISTER AGIUS THIS ALSO WANT TO
ECHO THE SAME OUTCOMES AS MY
COLLEAGUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD AND ALSO
LIKE TO BE AND IS QUITE THE
POSSIBLE THANKS.
O. I WANTED THEM TO WANT TO MISS
THE BOAT.
I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED TO. THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD AND I AND AND
THAT ONE WORD FOR WORKING WITH
YOU ON IT.
MISTER SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CULTURAL.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
SO I.
BUSTER ALLAN A SOUTHERNER BERMAN
AYE BERMAN AYE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOTES STANDS FORTY
ZERO.
AND WILL LEAVE THE ROOM.
THAT I THINK IS OUT.
BELIEVE IT OPENS.
BELIEVE IT OPEN FOR FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON.
.
AND MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO.
YEAH THAT'S WHY I WAS LOOKING SO
CAN. LIKE HE SAID WE HAVE PLAYED
ALL RIGHT THEY WERE READY TO BE
WITNESSES TO ANY BILL BUT.
THERE WERE NO.
ALRIGHT.
EVER YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
ALRIGHT DUBBED.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED PRISON A BE. FIFTEEN
FIFTY TWO WHICH ENCOURAGES
PUBLIC HEWLETT UTILITIES TO
PROMPTLY PAY A VENDOR WHO HAVE
SUBMITTED A VALID INVOICE
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES A UTILITY THAT IS
ALREADY MANDATED. TO USE TO
PARTICIPATE AN A SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY OUT PROGRAM TIP PAY AN
UNDISPUTED INVOICES BY THE
PAYMENT DATE.
SPECIFIED IN THE CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT.
OR THIRTY DAYS IF NO DATE AS
SPECIFIED SHOULD THE UTILITY
FAILED TO MAKE A TIMELY PAYMENT
THE BILL REQUIRES THE UTILITIES
TO PAY CERTAIN SMALL BUSINESS
VENDORS A LATE PAYMENT PENALTY.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN UTILITIES
EXPEND IN NINE POINT SEVEN
BILLION THROUGH THE SUPPLIER
DIRT DIVERSE CITY NETWORK OVER
THE YEARS THESE CONTRACTS HAVE
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
EXPANDING THE POOL OF POTENTIAL
BIDDERS AND. PROVIDED REVENUE TO
NEW AND EMERGING BUSINESSES THE
OVERALL SUCCESS OF THE SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAM CAN HOWEVER BE
UNDERMINED WHEN VENDORS ARE NOT
PAID IN A TIMELY FASHION. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO IS MODELED
AFTER SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS AND
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS FOR
PUBLIC PIC.
PART FOR CURE MEN OPPORTUNITY.
OPPORTUNITIES IN MY GOODNESS
WITH ME TODAY ARE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN THE PORT INCLUDING
THE SPONSOR THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. OUT IN IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL LET
THEM INTRODUCE THEMSELVES IN WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE OKAY GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRETT BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN INDIAN CHAMBER
COMMERCE A CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE FIVE
TWO. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONGSTANDING HISTORY WAS PROM
PAY BILLS THROUGHOUT THE VARIOUS
CODE SECTIONS TO PROTECT SMALL
BUSINESSES A SMALL BUSINESSES IT
PUTS OUT FUNDING FOR MATERIALS
AND SUPPLIES. NOT ONLY IF ON TOP
OF PAYROLL IN HEALTH CARE IN THE
IN THE VITAL THAT THEY PROVIDE
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND WHEN
THEY ARE PAID ON TIME THAT PUTS
HIM IN A VERY DIFFICULT POSITION
OF BEING STRETCHED BUT MAYBE
POSSIBLY HAVING TO POSTPONE
FURTHER.
PARTICIPATION IN CONTRACTS THE
THE THE JOE ONE FIFTY SIX
PROGRAM'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN BRINGING MINORITY AND SMALL
BUSINESSES INTO THE ROUND AND.
OF SUPPLY CONTRACTS FOR THE
UTILITIES THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE
THE PROP PAY BILLS. PROPERTY.
STATUTES ARE INSUFFICIENT AND
WE HOPE TO REMEDY THAT WITH ME
ALSO IS STACEY TRIP STATE A
TRACY STAN HUFF WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE AS
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY.
.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. IT IS
UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS BILL IS A
REMEDY FOR ON AN ISSUE BUT THE
ISSUE IS BECAUSE OF THE FIXED
SUCCESS OF A GREAT PROGRAM GEO
ONE FIFTY SIX.
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OF MANY
MINORITY ASSOCIATIONS RIGHT NOW
BUT MAINLY FOR ITS CHANGED
INDIAN COUNTRY FOR SO MUCH THE
BETTER. AND ARM THE PROGRAM IS
AN AWESOME PROGRAM IT'S IT'S
HELPED US GROW OUR BUSINESSES
WE'VE MET MADE NUMBERS OF JOBS
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF JOBS
AS A RESULT OF THIS THEN ADDED
TO THE TAX ECONOMY.
SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS A
LITTLE SUPPORT IN PROVIDING A
FRAMEWORK IN POLICY FOR HELPING
US.
HELP OURSELVES IN AND MAINTAIN
OUR CASH FLOW IN A IN A
MEANINGFUL MANNER. AGAIN WE
DON'T WANT TO BE ADVERSARIAL
WITH UTILITIES WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIR. TO HELP US WITH ON
PROVIDING A GREAT POLICY FOR
MOVING FORWARD IN A PROMPT PAY
FASHIONS WE THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS AND ASK YOU
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR VOTE TO
HELP US.
SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION.
BY.
SUMMER RETREAT IS.
SECONDED BY MYSELF
SAID PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY WILL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HEARD EXCUSE ME WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I ALWAYS FORGET JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
ITEM SIX AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK
SILVA AYE. VICE CHAIR ALAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURN AYE BERMAN
AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE VOTES
STANDS FIVE ZERO.
AND WILL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN.
BEFORE WE MOVE ON I WANT TO
WELCOME MISTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON TO OUR COMMITTEE.
WELCOME AND.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
WE ARE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AND.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
LOOK.
MISTER SECRETARY DO YOU LIKE TO
CALL WORLD.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
QUIRK SILVA AYE VICE CHAIR ALAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SOME MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE.
VOTES STANDS FIVE ZERO.
DO YOU HAVE.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM
TWO WHICH IS AB NINE SIX TO AND.
AYE. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE OR
EXPLAIN INTERNET.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP ON THE STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINE NOT THE
FINANCING FOR SEAPORTS AYE MR
ALLEN IS NOT HERE SO WE. WILL
HAVE OUR CONSULTANT ON TONY
SIMON'S GIVE A LITTLE
BACKGROUND.
AND THANK YOU MEMBER SAYS AB
NINE SIX TWO ITEM TO.
THE BILL I'M ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS BY WHICH HARBOR AGENCIES
WHICH A PREDOMINATELY R.
EXCLUSIVELY PUBLIC ENTITIES.
THAT THEY CAN HELP TO MONETIZE
THE VALUE. OF THE AYE AND NEW
FACILITY NEW EQUIPMENT OR A
PROCESS.
SO THAT.
PREMISE OF THIS IS THAT OUR
PORTS HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
OTHERS HAVE SAID THEY'VE DONE A
GOOD JOB AND. REDUCING THEIR
EMISSIONS AND ADOPTING.
IMPORTANT UP. AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE
HOWEVER THOSE POLICIES HAVE
COST.
AND THEREFORE THE PORTS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IN THE POSITION TO GO
AND DO FURTHER.
EXPENDITURES.
UNDER THIS PROCESS IT WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE.
TO REVIEW WHAT FACILITY OR
EQUIPMENT.
PURCHASE WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY WOULD EVALUATE THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THAT TO THE STATE
THEY'D BE LOOKING AT JOBS SALES
TAX BY BOTH STATE AND LOCAL. LOS
WE LOOKING AT HEALTH BENEFITS.
THESE ANALYSES HAVE TO BE DONE
UNDER SOUND ECONOMIC PRINCIPLES
REVIEWED UNDER A THIRD PARTY.
AND THAT.
COST BENEFIT TO THE STATE OVER
OVER TIME WILL THAT INFORMATION
BE PRESENTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BANK.
THE BANQUET REVIEW THAT CONFIRM
THAT THE WORK WAS DONE PROPERLY.
AND UNDER THE AMENDMENTS AT THE
COMMITTEE I'M IS BEING ASKED TO
ADOPT THAT THEY WOULD THEN ADOPT
A RESOLUTION THAT WOULD EITHER
BE. THE LESSER OF.
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
FUTURE VALUE OF DOING THE NEW
WEEK INSTALLING THE NEW
EQUIPMENT. OR FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE COST OF THE EQUIPMENT.
THE I. BANK WOULD THEN SUBMIT
THAT INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHO WOULD
INCLUDE THAT AS A PROPOSED
APPROPRIATION. WITH THE N.
EITHER THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSED BUDGET OR UNDER BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALSO WAY AND
AND I'VE WE WOULD OF COURSE ALSO
BE LOOKING AT THE SAME
INFORMATION.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR
JOINING US
HOPE YOUR BILL WAS JUST VERY
ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBED BY A
CONSULTANT SO IF YOU HAVE ANY.
OTHER REMARKS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M HERE SAID
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY TWO WHICH WILL
CONTINUE TO DIVERSIFY THE
FINANCING PORTFOLIO FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS.
FIRST MR BY THANKING THE
CHAIRWOMAN ENTER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL ARE
NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT TO AS
WE'VE BEEN MOVING FORWARD.
I'M TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE'VE WORKED ON THE
PAST COUPLE WEEKS.
SO INTERNATIONAL TRADE IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
NATION'S ECONOMY AND
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN SERVING OUR NATION'S
TRADE NEEDS.
FORTY PERCENT OF THE TOTAL
CONTAINERIZED CARGO ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES ARRIVED CALIFORNIA
PORTS AND WAS THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE NATION'S EXPORTS FLOW
THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S WELL.
TRADE IS A MAJOR DRIVER
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTE NO WAS
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY.
PORT ACTIVITIES ALSO EMPLOY MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AND GENERATE AN
ESTIMATED NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE AND LOCAL REVENUE.
ANNUALLY IS NOT TO MENTION ALL
THE ECONOMIC EFFECT ALL OF THESE
JOBS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO ONE OF THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE SYSTEMS OF PORTS
IN THE NATION INCLUDING THREE OF
AMERICA'S LARGE CONTAINER PORTS.
AND A DIVERSE SYSTEM OF SMALLER
PORTS AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
TWO IS AN INNOVATIVE WAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORTER HERE
INTERNATIONAL TRADE ECONOMY. AND
TO ENSURE THAT OUR PORCH REMAIN
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER PORTS
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY.
I THE WAKE OF THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AND OTHER ECONOMIC
TOúN TOOLS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
I CALIFORNIA HAD REVAMPED ITS
PUBLIC FINANCING TOOLS PROVIDE
FOR ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS ALSO KNOWN
AS E. AYE FTC'S.
AND ON THE HEELS OF THE
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT OF AB SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR ISIDORE HALL IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. I WHICH ALSO
CREE NEITHER FOR REPORT
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES.
SO IN SHORT EIGHTY NINE SIX TWO
IS GOING TO CREATE A NEW PUBLIC
FINANCING PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE
FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN OUR POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE MISTREAT
ADMINISTRATED BY STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK AD I
BELIEVE IT ANDREW.
ADD TO IT WITH THE.
PMSA IS ALREADY SPOKEN SO WITH
THAT
NO ANDREAS NOT ALWAYS NOT.
WE MY CONSULTANT WHERE XANDER.
XANDER HERE.
A MEASURE OR GET OUT YOUR JUST
WAITING TO SPEAK BUT YOU HAVEN'T
SPOKEN.
WILL I STAND CORRECTED TOYS
ALREADY THIS MORNING SO I HAVE
AND YOU'RE WITH THE FOR PMSA.
AND HE WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU
EVEN MORE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALLEN I DON'T
HAVE MUCH TO ADD KNOWS BEEN WELL
LAID OUT I JUST WANT TO.
POINT TO THE FACT THAT* A
PROG A BROUGHT THIS PROPOSAL FOR
IT AND TWENTY SIXTEEN WE THINK
IT'S A EXCELLENT IDEA WE ARE
PUTTING SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
CHECKS AND BALANCES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE VALUATION WHICH
REALLY SETS THE AMOUNT OF THE
APPROPRIATION AS GOVERNED BY THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT. AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THE AMENDMENT
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT A WAIT
UNTIL ADOPTION AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. GIVEN THE.
DEADLINES THAT WERE FACING FOR
THIS BILL TO MOVE THROUGH WITH.
IN THE LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR.
WE THINK THAT THE STATE HAS
SAID SOME VERY AGGRESSIVE GOALS
WHEN IT COMES TO GRAINY
EQUIPMENT AT THE PORTS.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PRESERVE COMPETITIVENESS.
WE ARE SEEING OTHER STATES
ACTUALLY INVEST IN THE REPORTED
FOR STRUCTURE. WITH THE WITHOUT
THE LEVEL OF CLEANLINESS THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IN THAT WE
SHOULD BE HAVING ON PORT
EQUIPMENT IN THE STATE.
AND SO HAVING A WAY TO DEVELOP A
WIN WIN.
AND PRESERVE THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE JOBS THESE
ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS FAMILY
SUPPORTING THE NECESSARILY NEED
A COLLEGE DEGREE.
AND THIS IS THE LAST BIG SECTOR
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
WHETHER BE AGRICULTURE A RETAIL.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT.
THE COMMITTEES SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL AND WE
ASK FOR GUY VOTE.
THANK YOU UP MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS.
AND GUY MOTION MOVE.
SECOND AND DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORT COMMENTS FROM OUR
GUESTS.
ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY CLOSING REMARKS VERY SIMPLY
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS ARE THE BEST
IN THE NATION ABOUT WHAT THIS
WILL ALLOW US TO DO IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING THE NEED
TO INVEST IN THESE PORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REMAIN COMPETITIVE.
BUSINESS THAT IS NOT GOING
CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY EASY FOR TO
OTHER STATES THE NORTH OF US
THREE Z. FOR MEXICO TO TAKE IT
TO THE SOUTH OF US.
AND THEN WE'RE ALSO SEEING
ENHANCED ACTIVITY FROM THE
EASTERN SEABOARD PORTS.
THERE'S A LOT OF OPTIONS IN
TODAY'S GLOBAL ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA HOUSE TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PORCH MEAN COMPETITIVE
THIS WILL ALLOW THEM THE
FINANCING THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS THIS IS ABSOLUTELY.
IS VITAL FOR OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY IT'S VITAL FOR THE THIS
THE ECONOMY OF THE UNITED STATES
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF THIS BUSINESS COMES TO
CALIFORNIA'S LET'S MAKE THE NEED
INVESTMENT AND LET'S GET THIS.
THANK YOU I'M JUST GONNA ASK YOU
TO KIND OF GIVE A SCENARIO OR AN
EXAMPLE TO SOME OF OUR VIEWERS
WHO MAY NOT BE AS INVOLVED WITH.
I BANK AND FINANCING WHAT WOULD
THIS LOOK LIKE FOR.
OF BUSINESS SOMEBODY WANTING TO
DO BUSINESS AT OUR PORTS
JUST GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF
ABSOLUTE ONE VENDOR IF YOU WANT
TO TAKE YOU OUT OF CHAIR
STRESSED AS.
A MARINE TERMINAL OPERATOR THE
PORTS ARE THEIR LANDLORDS.
BUT THE ACTUAL.
MOVEMENT OF THE CARGO ARE
HANDLED BY PRIVATE. COMPANIES
THAT ARE THE LEASE TENETS OF THE
PORCH
SO FOR LEASE TENANTS SAY SSA
MARINE.
I WANTED TO COME FORWARD AND
BILL.
OR INSTALL A PIECE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE OF A CARGO
HANDLER EQUIPMENT OR QUITE A
CRANE THAT CURRENTLY OPERATES
UNDER DIESEL.
AND WANTED TO MOVE TO SAY AND
ELECTRIFIED CREE.
BUT THE COST OF THAT.
WAS MORE THAN THE POOR COULD
JUSTIFY AND THE TENANT BASED ON
THE CURRENT ECONOMICS OF THE
PRICE OF MOVING CARGO AND THE
TARIFF RATES THAT THEY CURRENTLY
CHARGE.
BUT THEY WANTED TO DO IT THERE
WAS A GOAL SET BY THE STATE AND
FRANKLY THAT THE PORT AND THE
REGIONAL AIR DISTRICT.
BUT THAT DIESEL CRANE COULD
WORK FOR YEARS.
AND HAD ALREADY BEEN PAID FOR IN
THE ECONOMIC MODEL THAT EXISTED.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE PORT TO
COME FORWARD GET EVALUATION HAVE
THE EVALUATION VERIFIED BY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK.
HAVE AN INDEPENDENT CONSULTANT
REVIEW IT. HAVE THE PORT MAKE A
RESOLUTION AND A FINDING THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE HIDE
LANDS ACT.
AND THEN BASED ON A FUTURE
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS CONFIRMED BY THE CURRENT
FINANCE.
THE WAR ERA AND APPROPRIATIONS
BASED ON EVALUATION.
SO THERE'S YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A
SEVERAL CHECKS IN THE PROCESS.
I JUST ASKED THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE IN THIS COMMITTEE WE
HEAR LOTS OF TERMINOLOGY AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT OUR VIEWERS
BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE SO MANY
OUT THERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE FOLLOWING ALONG
WITH US AND.
UNDERSTANDING HOW THESE
INVESTMENTS.
I CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE NOT
ONLY IN OUR ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO
IN OUR AND BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
OUR ECONOMY.
YEAH SO IT MANAGER RIGHT I BUT
THAT INTO PLAIN ENGLISH TO FRAME
IT HAPPENS TO BE VIEWING OR ANY
MEDIA THAT'S COVERING US.
VERY SIMPLY OUR PORTS PAIN
CONSTANT INVESTMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE BEST PORTS IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY THIS IS NOT
JUST FOR ENVIRONMENT IS ALSO FOR
MOVING CARGO. BUT IT ALL RELATES
TO CALIFORNIA'S PORTS BEING THE
MOST COMPETITIVE PORTS IN THE
NATION AND MOST HELIPORTS IN THE
WORLD. THIS ALLOWS OUR PORTS TO
MAKE THE CORRECT ECONOMIC
DECISIONS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR REPORTS
REMAIN THE MOST COMPETITIVE
BECAUSE IN TODAY'S GLOBALIZED
ECONOMY IT'S VERY SIMPLE FOR
BUSINESS TO GO ELSEWHERE. IN
EITHER NORTH OF US THE SOUTH OF
US OR AROUND THE COUNTRY FROM US
AND THEY CAN BYPASS CALIFORNIA
ENTIRELY. THIS SIMPLY GIVES OUR
PORTS AWAY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN GET THE NET THE NECESSARY
FUNDING TO MIX WITH THE MOST
COMPETITIVE THE MOST ENERGY
EFFICIENT. ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY.
SIMPLY PUT THE PASSPORTS FOR
PEOPLE TO USE THIS SUPPORT
EVERYBODY THAT WORKS OUR PORTS
THE SUPPORTS OUR ENTIRE STATE'S
ECONOMY. ALLOWS CALIFORNIA
MAINTAIN ITS POSITION AS AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AND IN THIS
BILL YET WE WE'VE SEEN OTHER.
LEGISLATORS WORK TOWARDS.
THE SCENE CONCEPTS THIS BILL IS
YET ANOTHER STEP AND IT'S
ANOTHER POSITIVE IMPACT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MAKE IN THE THE
OVERALL ECONOMIC PARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MAKING SURE
REALLY WERE PROTECTING NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA'S JOBS BUT OUR
ECONOMY BECAUSE THIS REALLY IS A
THIS IS ONE OF OUR KEY
GEOGRAPHIC IN STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGES THAT WE HAVE THE
SPORTS SO FRESTON NEGLECT THEM
AND NOT ALLOW THEM THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO STATE. THE MOST
COMPETITIVE I WOULD BE DOING A
DISSERVICE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND THIS BILL WOULD CORRECT
THAT.
THANK YOU AND NOT SAY WE HAVE
ALL THIS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
AGREE WITH THAT RIGHT MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT WE HAVE A A.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
MISTER SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK
SILVA AYE VICE CHAIR ALAN AYE
AYE ALLEN AYE.
SOME NUMBER BERMAN.
BERMAN I ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE AS A MEMBER
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE.
VOTE STAND SIX TWO ZERO.
ALRIGHT I THAT WAS OUR LAST ITEM
ON ON A TODAY'S AGENDA BUT WILL
GO HEAD AND.
FOR THOSE WHO WERE NOT HERE
EARLIER WILL LIST THE CALL AND
GO CAN YOU GO AHEAD AND.
START WITH OUR FIRST ITEM.
THANK YOU.
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN.
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. VICE
CHAIR ALAN AYE. ALLEN AYE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE.
OKAY WE HAVE THAT BILL THAT IS
OUT.
AB FOUR TO SEVEN IS OUT.
ITEM TWO.
I WE JUST DID THAT ONE ALRIGHT.
THAT BILL IS OUT AB NINE SIX TWO
IS OUT.
THEN WE HAD ITEM FIVE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SEVEN.
I AM FIVE AB FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN
MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VICE
CHAIR ALAN.
ALLEN I SOME OF PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE VOTE STAND SIXTY
ZERO.
AND I DIDN'T. THAT BILL IS OUT
WE HAVE ITEM SIX A BE FIFTEEN
FIFTY TWO ITEM SIX AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
UTILITIES AND ENERGY.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
ALLEN AYE VOTE STAND SIX ZERO.
AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
ALLEN I.
BUT STAND SIX ZERO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THAT DILUTES OUT. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR ATTENDING.
YOU'RE WELCOME